-I feel, like it's almost cliché
now that we always open
when you're here talking about
how much has happened,
but today -- I mean, again
you have a show
not even a little bit
more than an hour from now
-Yep.
-And things we found out in just
the last couple hours --
Mike Pompeo was on that call
Rudy Giuliani
has been subpoenaed
by three different committees,
and supposedly Donald Trum
asked Australia --
the Australian Prime Ministe
to coordinate with AG Barr
in investigating the beginning
of the Mueller investigation
-Correct.
-That's a lot.
-It's a lot.
-Yeah.
-I mean, it is really --
The last week has been
pretty nuts, and I think -
You know, you think about
politics and crises
and moments of sort of
kinetic dynamism, and you know
there's this idea that thing
happen in a linear fashion
like you're painting a room,
you know?
And when you're painting a room,
you always know where you ar
and how much left to go,
but it's a lot more like
a stuck lid jar.
Right?
Like, you sort of go at it
You go at it.
You go at it and it pops off
And, you know, when you look a
sort of these moments in history
whether it's Watergate,
whether it's just
reading history
of other countries
and other times.
Like, things take longer t
happen than you think they wil
and then they happen faste
than you can imagine.
-Right.
And now it does seem like it's
happening very quickly.
You kind of called this
last time you were here.
You had a nice analogy to
Oedipus that I want to sho
because it does feel like
what you were saying
was gonna happen happened.
Let's take a look.
-The case is very strong and
the politics are very strong
And you've got the Democrati
leadership, like, holding back
the reins, and the whole thing
feels like a Greek play.
In act two where it's like -
it's like Oedipus is gonna
end up with his mom.
[ Laughter ]
-And now it seems like
it's happening.
-Yes. Yes.
I mean, the whole --
From the moment
this Congress took over,
it felt kind of faded in a way
Right?
And partly that's
because of the --
primarily it's because of
the behavior of this president
the way he conducts himself.
The manifest lawlessness
with which he stewards
the nation's affairs
or stewards his own affairs,
which he can't
distinguish between,
and the fact that the Congress
was elected
to sort of provide
some kind of oversight.
And those two things seemed on
the collision course
from the first day.
And it was a collision
that I think
Nancy Pelosi desperately
wanted to avoid.
-Yeah.
-But at a certain point
it became unavoidable
in the last seven days.
-Obviously I want to talk abou
Republican reaction to this,
but you mentioned Nancy Pelosi
and it did seem as though
what has happened
in this last week
is this sort of newly electe
moderate Democrats
from sort of swing districts
a lot of whom have backgrounds
in national security.
They seem to be the ones
who have been the final step
the sort of tipping point
elected officials.
-Yeah, and I think that,
you know, there's about 40 or so
that came out in a big chunk
after the call notes
were released.
And I think that has -- there'
a few things going on there.
One, the facts are
just indefensible.
So I think there's actually just
a first order
subsided belief
by a lot of them.
Like, this is impeachable
conduct and we have to say so,
or at least
it merits an inquiry.
And then the second thing is
the theory of the case was
"We're gonna beat this guy
in the ballot box in 2020.
If he's running around
the world, rigging the election,
then you might have
a harder time beating him.
Right?
It's not a retrospective
investigation
to what happened in 2016.
It's some kind of
deterrent effect
on what he might get up to
in 2020.
And I think that just the
clarity of that in that moment
when people think to themselves,
"Well, what exactly is he doin
on these phone calls?
What does he say to Mohammad bin
Salman when he calls him up?
What does he say
to Vladimir Putin?
What does he say to other folk
about how they can help hi
win 2020?"
-Right.
-That got people really to
understand that the stakes
were very, very clear
and present and firm.
-And I think -- and one thing we
can all take away is,
he's never had a phone call in
his life where it hasn't bee
about "What can you do for me?
-[ Laughs ]
Exactly.
-He's never picked up the phon
and started with, "How are you?"
-Right, yes.
Or about U.S. policy.
-Yeah.
-I mean, that's part of
what's so striking about
those call notes.
There's nothing
in the call notes
about U.S. policy
towards Ukraine.
-Right.
-The Ukrainian side has al
sorts of policy objections
"We need more money
and we need more Javelins.
Please send us those arms.
We're psyched to buy
some more oil from you."
-Yeah.
-Donald Trump's, like
"Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Here's what I need from you.
-Right, yeah.
-As Donald Trump.
And that's, to me, the kind of
fundamental sin here,
is that the man who is taske
with representing all of u
as a public representative o
the American body politic,
cannot constitutionally
conceive of himself
other than self-interest.